faire encore et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salue ces deux oui
j'ai rencontré chloé qui tembo désolé
puisqu'ici me dérange trop plein qui
était maussade parle
plus kembo c'est une influence us belge
de 26 ans
qui à plus de 500 milles abonnés sur
instagram est pas loin de 100 nuits sur
youtube dans une nouvelle vidéo et a
décidé de nous raconter ses échecs
[Musique]
ok ça vaut quoi
ok on va recommencer ma vie honnêtement
comment était tombé en france
mon enfance j'ai grandi
avec ma mère
je visiterai baisse un projet
[Musique]
mais ouais c'était quoi tu me plains pas
ouais ouais j'ai pas me plaindre
mais petit tu fais pas venir influencer
nos coachs des petites baies en fait
j'aimais déjà trop le monde artistique
tout cas je voulais devenir une styliste
1 je veux pas devenir une danseuse
tout santé à ta place à l'école
vraiment pas que l a plus un esprit
créatif alors l'école c'est pas trop son
fort à la fin de la primaire al hajja
redouble une fois elle rêve qu'une seule
chose intégrer une école spécialisée
dans les arts mais vous savez très bien
les métiers artistiques et les parents
ça fait deux
famer à la peur pour elle qu'elle trouve
pas de travail en faisant un métier
artistique à leurs classiques elle la
route vers un lycée général et classic
clay est fini par décrocher jets
classiques parce que vous et moi on sait
très bien quand on choisit pas notre
orientation finit toujours par des
crochets
[Musique]
tu rentres dans le secondaire ouais à 12
ans
oui
j'avais déjà doublé une année ouais
d'accord ok 13 ans j'avais 13 ans ouais
je rentre à 14 ans
j'ai raté le bus je suis arrivé en
cinquième et au final les profits m'ont
dit que je devais aller dans une
direction professionnelle
plus précisément la vente et j'ai dit oh
non
je pars
partir de l'école ça m'a vraiment fait
du mal je me suis senti comme un échec
j'ai dit à quel âge et j'ai échoué on va
te le fait de voir tout le monde qui
suit un chemin classique et réussir et
toi tu as été sur le bord de la route
suivi trop grave je connais moi je me
rappelle qu'en septembre et septembre
c'est la rentrée et en fait à tout le
monde qui va là les meilleures séquences
d merlis et de paris et toi tu vois tu
es là avec les autres et en fait à ce
moment là tu dis je crois que mon destin
il est bien il au quartier haute il a
lâché moi tu dis qu'il est souvent chez
moi j'ai pas réussi tu commences conte
et les réseaux sociaux
je commençais réseau un peu plus tard je
commence en 2012 et décide alors de
travailler pour subvenir à ses besoins
et de se consacrer à son métier
d'influenceurs non c'est pas bon c'est
pas bon et de se consacrer entièrement à
son métier d'influencé et à sa chaîne
youtube
on est bien venu sur ma chaîne salut tu
demanderais bien vous sur machine qui se
passe c'est que pendant trois ans et
gagne pas d'argent ça vous avez qui fait
cette vidéo n'oubliez pas de cliquer et
vous abonner tout ça sans agence
indépendante
[Musique]
dans ta tête c'est ce que tu dis tu sais
où tu vas ouais non absolument pas ce
nom ça me fait ça me faisait pas peur
parce que
j'étais vraiment bon on va pas dire
borné mais voilà je vivais pour moi en
fait je faisais ce que je voulais parce
que j'en avais besoin réduisez liste
noire c'est vraiment un mois par faye
est tellement tellement noir j'ai
vraiment fait organiquement tu vois j'ai
appris je suis tombé 10 fois tu vois
mais je me suis relevé que c'est votre
me
paie la persévérance tu dis ok c'est il
ya ça mais c'est pas grave ça m'arrête
pas on continue
oui mais
et tu rêvais toujours de faire du chant
quelque part
à cette époque là j'ai commencé à y
penser
[Musique]
super après trois ans persévérance ça
commence enfin à marcher pour elle ça
que j'aime bien avec le lhc est une
marque de cosmétiques m'invite au
festival coachella à los angeles en
californie pour y créer du contenu en
gros pour qu'il fait et cette année là
avec beyoncé en redline
[Applaudissements]
ça a réveillé quelque chose en elle
cette envie de se lancer dans la musique
ses revenus dans son coeur
alors chloé elle revient et se remet
enregistrés
mais elle a jamais rien sorti parce
qu'elle trouvait pas en elle cette force
pour assumer son rêve
là on fait aussi ça commençait à pas
m'ennuyer mais un tout qui manquait je
me voyais pas faire ça toute ma vie en
fait
[Musique]
le côté musique qui était en fait il m'a
toujours fait coucou mais j'ai toujours
un peu tu vois ce que je veux dire on va
te l'a tellement renier qu'au final je
ne sais pas de quel était le vrai
problème voilà green hills et ça
va vraiment commencer à te lancer en
2021 qu'est-ce qui a été l'élément
déclencheur
en fait je commençais et puisque j'étais
vraiment en train de procrastiner là la
musique est en fait ça a commencé à
jouer sur mon mental je me sentais mal
il y avait quelque chose qui n'allait
pas mais j'y arrivais pas je vous ai mis
ça peut être la musique quand même ne me
dis pas que si je fais de la musique je
vais être heureuse mais en fait tu es sa
g
tous domaines on suit
[Musique]
donc en 2021 tu le trouve où ce courage
déclic en fait ce qui fait que tu dis
j'y vais mais déjà je le trouve à partir
du moment où si pas tout ce que tu vas
faire qui doit être parfait déjà parce
que déjà été dans les débuts bien sûr ça
va pas être parfait il faut assumer ce
truc là donc tu as fait ton premier clip
en
pendant toutes ces années j'ai été
confronté à des situations des personnes
des relations toutes ces choses là on
fait en sorte que en fait m'ont poussé
vers mon but et c'est comme ça que tu ai
voulu
quant à un obstacle tu regardes pas ok
il ya la difficulté de l'obstacle et
tout mais après qu'est ce que t'en tires
moi je trouve ça c'est très mou et si je
te demander un secret pour réaliser ses
rêves
un secret pour réaliser ses rêves
je pense qu'il faut rester connecté à
soi-même toujours alors si tu as
déjà vu un biberon
qui a déjà vu un bébé ne jamais tomber
en apprenant à marcher clos elle est
comme moi elle est comme toi elle est
comme nous tous c'est ça que j'aime bien
avec elle c'est on tombe on qu'on
apprend à marcher je perds jamais soit
je gagne sur j'apprends
[Musique]
ah oui j'oubliais abonne toi la chaîne
de visite à des personnes que tu veux je
contacte tu as un influenceur que chip
east luge à lui parlé d'un footballeur
tu veux que je lui parle qu'à un temps
certes je lui parle d'un président tu
veux que je lui parle en vend moins dé m
mais en commentaires sur youtube peu
importe mais bien on discute ensemble j
en parle bien c'est notre chaîne et on
se tape débat est bien c'est que a
[Musique]